good evening and welcome to this
strategy and resources committee meeting
on thursday the 16th of september 2021
my name is councillor richard siddall
and i am the chairman of the committee
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few housekeeping
issues to run through
members the setup for this meeting has
been designed to mitigate for covid
therefore can ask all present to work to
the protocols agreed by the council on
the 2nd of september 2021
we are streaming live
as well as recording and being present
in the meeting you are giving your
consent to be recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up to indicate if
you wish to speak i will then invite you
at the appropriate time
please try and reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible and ensure that your
microphones remain off when not speaking
finally can i draw your attention to the
notice of the agenda papers regarding
different levels and the
advice about the fire exit
one of the things i would like to raise
before we start the uh
meeting
is
an announcement from me and one of the
things i would like to
remind members is that early in the year
we set organizational values
of respect and fairness
these values were agreed by this
committee
and full council in the year earlier in
the year
we've also agreed to the formation of
the equalities diversity and inclusivity
working group
which i'm pleased to have said that
we've met and an action plan will be
presented to the committee later in the
year
the officers have made an excellent
start and we hope that the council in
the district can lead the way in this
area
having created a strategy and have
identified the need for a working group
to promote these quality diversity
is very disheartening when some members
do not appear to abide and act on these
values
one of the things we talked about
at the working group was the correct use
of pronouns
this is particularly important when
ensuring that people are shown respect
i am a member of the lgbtq plus
community
and as part of that i am a gay man
i therefore
prefer to be called the pronouns he and
him
my title at this committee is chairman
although i do prefer chair although at
this time it is not a convention of the
council
i must admit that i was very offended
and disappointed at the last snr
committee meeting when i was not showing
respect not only as a chair of this
committee but also as a gay man i heard
hope that after my experience at this
council in the last two years that we
had learnt about diversity this does not
to be seen to be the case and i was
called madam chairman on several
occasions during that meeting
i can only imagine this was done to
undermine me this type of behavior no
longer reflects the values of the
council and it does not fit within our
aims inclusivity i hope this does not
happen again
thank you
item number two uh tara could have
apologies for absence uh thank you
chairman apologies and received from
councillor jarvis thank you thank you
councillor channel
ah thank you chairman in relation to
your statement can i just put on record
i wasn't present at that meeting of snr
if you're talking about the last meeting
in july so just like that one record
that i wasn't there so in no way i hope
any of those comments are attributed to
me about the disrespect you felt you
were saying german they
the channel thank you
so now move on to ice number three which
is the minutes of of the meeting held on
the 15th of july on pages 5 to 22 are
approved as a true and accurate record i
submit do i have a second to please
cancel this way
does any member wish to raise any
matters of accuracy that they need to
indicate that they wish to speak on
no okay thank you very much
so now move on to item number four which
is disclosure of interest
to disclose the existence of nature of
any disposable puny peculiar interest
other puni communities or non-particular
interests relating to the items of
business on the agenda having regards to
paragraph 68 inclusive of the code of
conduct for members
i would also like to remind members
that should any items come up during the
meeting to disclose them at the time
councillor boyce
thank you chairman um
gender item seven i declare a
non-pecuniary interest i'm a i'm
chairman of a
arms house trust
uh which may
be affected by this
gender item okay thank you council voice
councillor durham
thank you chairman it's a non-pecuniary
interest um probably in relation to item
seven on the agenda being a member of
essex county council thank you
councilwoman councillor
thank you chairman um like um councillor
boyce gender item number seven i'm going
to declare that i'm a trustee
of um
an arms house charity and actually i
will apply it to
just about embraces gender item number
eight as well chairman thank you thank
you
councillors
thank you chairman just also like cancer
durham i'm a member of essex county
council i think anything on there that's
non-pecuniary chairman okay chairman
just did we agree the minutes by scent
yes did we oh i'm sorry i must have been
slow i didn't hear that
okay
uh
so moving on to item five which is
public participation participation and i
could advise that i've not received any
submissions from members of the public
so now we move on to item number six
approval of duty to cooperate strategy
on pages 23 to 54. mr winslow strategy
policy and communications manager
is going to present the report thank you
mr winslet
thank you chair
firstly i must draw the committee's
attention to page 41 of the report which
has a minor error on it which is on the
front cover to appendix 2.
please could the committee note that the
date on the front should read september
2021 and not june 2021 as printed in the
report
as the committee will recall from its
meeting on the 15th of june it approved
a draft duty to cooperate strategy for
targeted consultation with other
prescribed public bodies subject to the
duty to cooperate
as a reminder this relates to a legal
duty of the planning and compulsory
purchase act 2004 as amended which
requires the council to cooperate with
other prescribed bodies to address
strategic and cross-boundary matters
these are identified in the national
planning policy framework or nppf and
i'll set out in more detail in section
3.3 of the report on page 23.
a six-week consultation was held during
june and july and concluded in 25
comments being received from seven duty
to cooperate bodies these are set out in
detail in appendix one which is called
the statement of consultation
since the consultations end the council
has also received positive feedback from
officers at rochford district council
and braintree district council
as set out in section 4.5 of the report
the overwhelming majority of comments
made supported the council's proposed
approach and either had no specific
comments to make or made their own
commitments to support modern district
council in the development of joint
evidence strategic issues and the ldp
review
some comments from specific consultees
have however resulted in changes to the
strategy to improve its effectiveness
as set out in section 6 of the report
it's now recommended that the committee
approves the duty to cooperate strategy
as set out in appendix 2 enabling it to
be used when engaging in the duty during
the ldp review and any other strategic
cross-boundary conversations with
prescribed bodies and i'm happy to take
any questions thank you mr milsler so
the recommendations are set out in the
report as follows
little one that the committee notes the
response received to the duty to
cooperate strategy
targeted consultation and recommended
changes as summarized in the mulder
district duty to cooperate statement of
consultations set out in appendix one
little two
that the append the updated modern
district duty to cooperate strategy has
set out in appendix to be approved do i
have a second to please councillor swain
uh
i now invite members to
speak on this item council channel
thank you very much chairman
can i just ask as a matter of process
bearing in mind
the terms of reference of both this
committee and of council and bearing in
mind what mr windsor has just referred
to in 3.3
and i appreciate that this is
strategic policies identified by the
mppf and i consider perhaps this might
come into that remit of strategic
policies and bearing in mind uh the
legality that we have to do and carry
out this and i would mention a to d
within the report referred to
um and bearing in mind d of this terms
of reference of this count um committee
review of the council's overall policy
framework and recommend on those plans
policies and strategies
except relating to public licensing and
risk management which are reserved to
council for approving adoption
can we approve this here or is this a
matter that really should go forward to
council bearing in mind other items on
the agenda which do have to go to
council and they are all intrinsically
linked so just ask that question
chairman if this strategy
actually is a fundamental issue of
policy that this authority must abide by
and therefore should it not be a matter
for council to determine and agree this
important document because it sets up
the framework regarding how the review
of our ldp we do consult with
stakeholders and other persons thank you
chad
councillor china i would like to answer
that question
mr winslow i'll take i'll take one part
of that which is to make a distinction
here that the other items on the agenda
um in respects of issues and options
report it's a specific function of
council to
approve that for consultation similarly
this committee's heard about the
statement of community involvement
before
and that is a statutory document which
must be approved by council there's no
legal obligation to prepare a duty to
cooperate strategy and therefore that is
a bit of a distinction
but i would have to
lean on mr dodds sudden to
determine whether or not he feels that
they should also go to council
sorry through you chairman
um
on reflection i think a recommendation
to council would be the
the belt and braces approach to this to
make sure that that we're
watertight on it so happy to
for that to be amended to to be a
recommendation to council thank you mr
dawson
any other points or questions
so uh we're going to change the
recommendation so that it's
uh to the council rather than to this
committee
yeah so item number two
yeah that's the only one i was referring
to yeah okay
cancel white thank you mr chairman
i've just got a query really um i've
seen here on the public bodies um the
local nature partnership
um and
it doesn't appear that essex has one and
um the government hasn't updated their
forms till 2015 is this going to replace
the um a lot of local bodies like um
that don't exist anymore
or is it something new so i haven't come
across it before that so i was i was
curious
mr winslet
thank you chad yeah the local nature
partnership for greater essex is
currently in preparation um it will have
a
similar status in the planning
arena as the south east local enterprise
partnership
we are advised by our colleagues at
county council that preparations are
underway whether draft structure et
cetera being discussed with the
government at the moment but it does
require government approval
sorry
any other points questions
uh so members can we agree that via
ascent
okay thank you very much
so we now move on to agenda item seven
affordable housing and commuter sum
strategy
mr lee lead specialist
to place to present the report mr lee
thank you chairman um
evening members um as many of you recall
on the 18th of march this year full
council agreed the
need to develop a strategy in relation
to affordable housing and commuted sums
um
it's envisioned by officers that it's
likely that there may be an increase in
applications coming forward that may not
be strictly policy compliant take into
account the five-year land supply
and that could either us as officers and
members
through committee may wish to support
some of them and others could be allowed
at appeal and it could end up in a
situation where the affordable housing
that would be acquired on these sites
would not be where as our housing
service would look to
provide affordable housing due to demand
or it could be that there's an issue in
relation to regis providers wanting to
take it such as a split of a flat block
um our
local plan policy does allow for
off-site contributions when
it is considered that the affordable
housing needs could be better satisfied
through
this route
and with that in mind the
strategy has been brought forward
and it lays down now they're
highlighting paragraph 3.2.2 of the pulp
the
an idea of when it is likely we would
look to accept a financial contribution
rather than on-site contribution i think
it's important to know when you look at
this this still is quite clearly saying
and showing that the council will still
first point of clarity always look for
on-site contributions still but this is
just giving our housing service a better
ability to push back where in theory we
could end up in a situation where they
wouldn't want any affordable housing on
site and we could actually in the
situation where we could not ask for
some and obviously it's better to to get
some financial contribution in that
respect the strategy also
explains
where we might like to use the commuted
sums because there is a lack of clarity
in that and obviously members i think
through s dealt with a number of reports
relatively recently where we've looked
to use those commuted terms
because there is a lack of clarity and
this gives some idea of where the
housing services look in the future to
like to be able to use that money
especially if obviously if it does
increase and that's laid down in section
3.2.3 of the poll
and that's really
it chairman thank you very much thank
you mr lee
so the recommendations are set out of
the report as follows
and this is to
counsel
the the affordable housing and commuted
some strategy set out an appendix one be
adopted do i have a second to please
counselor swain thank you very much
uh councillor boyce
thank you chairman um
in principle i'm i'm quite happy uh with
this recommendation
however
um
what concerns me
is that any development in any town or
village
especially in villages
where there is an affordable housing
element
that should come forward
the
the residents of that village
would want to have the social housing
uh rather than a commuted sum that's
going to go to another part possibly to
another part of the district
um uh and i'm i'm minded
uh of the situation
where i think it's called the um of
people's village at burnham or something
i look to mrs stan um the recent
application that was refused
where
they didn't want any affordable housing
on the site i think was to 300 units and
there was a sum
and i think this was all in the public
domain
so somebody
jump on me if i'm wrong of 2.4 million
pounds offered in place of social
housing
now
i think members need to retain
some input in how this
whether
the commuted sun be used how it is used
and also
i'm sure the ward members would prefer
the social housing
within that development
so with those caveats
i'm quite happy to go along providing we
can build in if it's supported by your
committee chairman uh we can build in
some safeguards for members to have some
involvement in this and i'll remind
you of my declared interest
because i may be speaking against the
interest of my
trust
uh who could could have been a recipient
of
such sons thank you jeremy uh mr lee can
you can you assure us at all on those
matters food chairman um firstly for
clarity just in relation to the
application was made reference the
applicant was quite happy to provide
on-site contribution it was actually our
housing service that would have
preferred a financial contribution they
they offered either or it was actually
our housing service that said that not
the applicant the clarity in relation to
um the requirement for the any
contribution to be
to me to be provided in the village ward
etc and that would actually be against
our
our planning policy obviously this
website this document is not a planning
document per se it's a housing document
aimed at our housing services rather
than the planning matters so
they'll like with the um tinker's hole
too um whether you want to if you know
burnham walters i think it's called or
um
you know officers made a recommendation
and as it said in the report that was
our recommendation to take the financial
contribution but if members had wanted
to grant permission they could have
actually have said no we wanted on-site
contribution and that'll be the same for
any planning application that comes
forward it will still be the decision of
the council whether or not we accept a
commuted some but this is just giving
some clarity for housing where they
can in how they can interpret the part
of the policy that says that and our
housing our affordable housing policies
clear it's to meet the needs of the
district it doesn't require any
community sum to be used within the
district it is clear it is to meet the
needs of the district
rather than where it is and so therefore
we can't put that in strategy because
that would conflict with actually with
our ldp policy and this is not a policy
this is just a strategy and guidance
thank you chairman
so answer your question mr council voice
uh not really okay
with respect to mr lee it seemed to be
uh i accept what he's yeah he's saying
yeah uh but i just fear that if
uh
with respect to officers here i just
fear that if officers suddenly have a
commuted sum offered to them
i don't believe any developer would want
to have social housing in their
development because it might make their
housing harder to sell
so the they would always prefer to claim
that nobody's interested in providing
social housing
um so i i think we need to still control
this
and we would still be able to control
that as part of planning wouldn't we
so the planning rules aren't changing so
we would still be able to to control
that as part of our planning permission
um yeah but uh sorry to come back sorry
um
but the fact is that if we have this
strategy
it will be writ large in developers
applications uh for um uh developments
mr lee
chairman i'm probably speaking slightly
out of turn because i'm sort of going
from presenting this report to probably
chief planning officer's hat on so i'm
slightly moving um but what i'll be
saying is from a development management
perspective our policy requires on-site
that is the starting point but our
policy does allow for an exceptional
circumstances a commuted some and all
this the idea of this strategy is that
it provides our housing service with
understanding of when they will or won't
accept that it does not
change the development management
process out any of our policies or the
decision makers
requirements when making a determination
of planning capitalization according to
the development plan as material
considerations it will not affect that
aspect of the process at all it's um
it's about supporting housing services
rather than planning application
decision making thank you chairman
absolutely councillor white
thank you mr man fair enough my concerns
are in a similar vein to council voices
um presumably this fund would be to
build new housing but my concern is how
will the financial contributions be
calculated
because presumably if this is they have
to do 40 affordable they might say the
40 affordable accounts to i don't know 2
million pounds
but will that take into account the land
value because of course the the
developers have got the land already
included in their permission so it
concerns me they're going to give a
certain amount of money to build it but
then whoever gets the money has then got
to buy the land to build the housing on
or give up their own land to build the
housing that's the first thing
and um who's going to ha to handle it
who's going to manage it and who's going
to audit it because my other concern is
it's going to go into a big pot which is
gonna get lost
and we're not actually going to see the
affordable housing on the ground um you
know so they're my concerns is really
the calculations of the contributions
because i don't want them to sort of cop
out and then the other thing is with
your 40 affordable can we make sure that
they can't then use that land mass to do
40
more
um market value housing because they'll
have their boundary drawn round wherever
they have the permission so i don't
think it's going to be in my mind quite
as simple as just saying well you know
give us two three four million i think
it needs to be really watertight we
can't go into this with our eyes closed
mr lee will it be watertight
for you chairman as the strategy
explains our policy on the financial
adopt the amount we have is already in
adopted spd and set down in that policy
um it's this strategy doesn't
impact on the actual level of financial
contribution we have because that is
already adopted by the council
and facilitated through our accept our
planning policies this just references
that
we do accept financial contributions
quite regularly for points of properties
already and
as all members know for snr through the
various reports we've had we have spent
that money on various matters or looking
to um so i don't see how this strategy
impacts on anything that's happening
currently with the financial
contributions that we receive thank you
leslie the money's not just going to
disappear is it
no absolutely not chair mine's good it's
pair it's uh externally audited um as
well
within our balance sheet okay thank you
very much
uh cancer sweet
the question of um
where one would like to see where we
would like to see affordable housing in
the future uh an important aspect of
the developing ldp
it is but i think that's a separate
attitude entity to this strategy so i
think i think those are two separate
things well i take councillor boyce's
point that obviously
most villages would
want to have some social housing but
that for various reasons such as
infrastructure provision and so on that
may not be
feasible or acceptable but
uh as part of the which we say the
developing settlement strategy
um
that the um
involvement or the inclusion of
affordable housing should be integrated
with that
which which would be part of ldp options
so which is separate to this strategy
um
is affordable housing mentioned in the
options so chairman
yeah
yeah that will be part of our ldp this
is that this is a completely separate
thing to that to our ldp so this is you
know setting out the strategy to ensure
that you know that we get contributions
in whatever way is necessary to ensure
that we have we do have affordable
housing that's my view
any other
uh
cancer lagging
hey chair um so just like i can
understand because obviously house is
not my uh specialism um so it's the sum
of money that comes in when we don't
have a contribution the money goes into
a pot
and then we spend that on affordable
housing in other places
that's clear thank you
and also
3.2
3.2.2 the bullet points there
the top bullet point it talks about the
location of proposed development is not
a sustainable suitable location
um they seem to have sustainability drum
down our throats that all applications
have to meet that and the first bullet
point says well you can do that if it's
not considered to be in a sustainable
location which causes me uh
it vexes me
and the rest of these areas just seem to
be yep we can do this if it meets this
criteria we can consider that to be able
to get the money
so what worries me is that we'd allow
target lead development so that we could
claim money to meet targets that are set
out for building houses and what would
worry me that it would be housing not
necessarily in what we would say as well
members in in the right locations so
that's a concern
which which leads me to think
i'm not keen on
supporting this in this format
yeah thank you
from my understanding though that that
in terms of where the affordable housing
will be is down to the planning and down
to our
ldp it's got nothing to do with this
strategy
so the two things are separate council
lagging yeah did i just come back get
would it be not be prudent to do some
more work on the ldp then come back and
look how this strategy would then flee
today doesn't need to be done
okay
thank you chair mr lee you chairman um
just
maybe maybe a little bit of background
on some of the bullet points might be
helpful for members understanding and um
and i thought maybe it's not helpful if
one sees me as planning you know head of
planning well actually obviously you
know this document is separate to plan
so maybe it's not helpful maybe with me
presenting it but unfortunately you
stuck with me tonight so um but one of
the issues obviously in relation to
sustainability would be that you know
applications will come forward as
officers and as members we do not
support
we know from five ten years ago the
members that were here know this as well
applications that we did not want to
support which we refused and we were
very anti as a council were allowed at
appeal
and it's you know and we need to be able
to
deal with that at the time we our
housing
figures you know the waiting list show
that in certain villages there's not
really a demand for affordable housing
if an application came in one of those
villages
and was offering four or five you know
ten houses however if
we're not able to house them with
residents of the district they will be
housed from residents outside of the
district and all of this is just is to
actually to stop that happening is to
make sure that where we do not need
affordable housing or where there is not
good benefits for example i know from
working in previous authorities when you
get a block of flats a registered
provider doesn't want three out of a
block of 10 because of the on costs we
don't end up in a situation where we
have
a block of 10 flats they're supposed to
give us floor four flats and then they
don't give us any that is where we don't
want to be because if nobody will take
it they'll go back to being market and
the point of this strategy is to mean
that when we get in those difficult
positions we're able to defend ourselves
for council to make sure that we can
provide housing for the net residents of
this district it i can promise you just
flip into header planning we are not
looking to be taking uh to go against
the policy with the dm process members
of the committee will still be able to
determine it that policy determine that
whether or not we accept it but this is
just about us protecting in situations
where as a council we probably don't
even necessarily want the development
but they can come forward and they can
be at one appeal or because of the
tilted balance we may need to accept it
um but yeah that's really these all
these bullet points have come through
from
my housing colleagues where they have
had struggle and issues with dealing
with affordable housing and having to
have debates and issues thank you sharon
okay thank you
um
and that's that's to me is the key thing
is is this is separate to our our
planning policies is about ensuring that
we get
revenue from situations where we
wouldn't normally and that's that's the
crucial thing about it council voice i'm
sorry to
be
dominating
and he gave a very good example of flats
within a a block so i understand that
problem but i thought we had a policy
that
that if a developer
claimed they could not
find anybody to take
the
the housing on
a social landlord we ourselves would
undertake it now
i
i think that was a policy
but if it isn't
that needs to be in our strategy
that we are prepared
to take it on ourselves
because that
could form part of our revenue street
screech stream in the future
we wouldn't get above 50 houses
which would
save us the need to set up a housing
fund
revenue account
um so
force the thought chairman okay any
comments from what i can see lots of
lots of i'll start over to mr leslie
because i think that's a finance
conference
i think there's absolutely merit in
exploring those areas what we haven't
done at the moment is actually going to
the details of the pros and cons and the
business plan for that side of it at the
moment and that's what we need to
understand actually what resources and
capacity do we need to deliver that and
how does it work we also need to be very
careful about the types of units we have
as well for example to go back to uh mr
uh
lee's example if we took say a couple of
flats in a block of flats
there are service charges to be paid for
that and actually service charges may be
paid at market rent rather than perhaps
the rate we could afford if you take
stream cases in london there's often
concierge services there could be
swimming pools gyms etc and perhaps
that's not an appropriate level um for
us to want to take on the best use of
funds for affordable homes so we need to
be very careful about what units and
selective around that and then we have
to do really a business case to
understand is it affordable and what
level is it affordable at two units is
that gonna cause us good problems ten
units is that optimum for us
when do we need to take on more staff so
i do absolutely applaud the uh the idea
and perspective and something perhaps
for us to look at and indeed uh that
could tie in with some of the work we do
uh have on train at the moment around
our um
expenditure of uh
section 106 monies as well so that's
something that could tie into that at a
later point but
i don't think we're there yet with the
evidence to actually make a decision uh
around that and if we did put in
something it would have to be quite
flexible to allow that to happen thank
you mr leslie
durham
yeah thank you
i recall conversations about this and
about the possibility of us starting to
build our own social housing etc but i
don't think it ever progressed
past the initial discussions
um
yeah i mean there are certainly merits
but as mr leslie said it's something we
need to go into in quite
yeah is it something new or yeah no mr
leslie sounds like a previous chief
executive okay who did not who did the
business case but did not take into the
equation the fact we own the property
okay
thank you councillor boyce so i am going
back to
the recommendation which is to the
council
uh that the affordable housing and
commute to some strategy be adopted
can we agree this via a cent
and see we have a seconder for that
recorded vote
okay
so can we record counseling
thank you very much members
so we now move on to
uh item number eight which is the local
development plan review issues and
options
found on pages
to 118
mr winslow again
thank you chair
so the purpose of this report is for the
committee to consider the local
development plan reviews issues and
options document with a review with a
view to recommending it to council for
approval to consult the public partners
and stakeholders in accordance
with regulation 18 of the town and
country planning regulations
the development of the issues and
options document is in direct response
to council's february 2021 approval of
the malden district local development
scheme
which commenced a review of the local
development plan which was originally
improved in 2017.
i set out in 3.3 of the report the
council established a cross-party
working group member working group which
has met on a number of occasions to
consider the whole of the ldp review
project
the challenges the district faces and
also consider the findings of the
evidence base as it emerges
there have also been two all member
workshops which have explored the
different policy areas that are covered
by the ldp review and to contribute into
the strengths weaknesses opportunities
and threats assessment of the district
which has in turn informed the
development of a 20-year vision and a
set of objectives
in addition you'll remember working
workshops and subsequent feedback from
members has supported the development of
the settlement pattern or hierarchy
which has been completed in-house by
officers
it's hoped therefore that this
demonstrates that the feedback from
these workshops and the ldp review
member working group has assisted in the
creation of the issues and options
document before you this evening
the document structure is set out in 4.1
i won't go through it in detail
but
to point out that there are seven
proposed spatial options to consult on
which should be looked at as concepts
for how growth could be accommodated in
the future followed by a series of topic
summaries and consultation questions
covering a range of planning policy
themes relevant to the malden district
developing an ldp review should be
shaped by early proportionate and
effective engagement between the council
and its communities as well as local
organizations businesses statutory
consultees infrastructure providers and
operators
assuming approval by this committee and
then council in november the issues and
options document would be subject to at
least a six-week consultation carried
out in accordance with the modern
district statement of community
involvement which was approved by
council in september i'm happy to take
any questions okay thank you mr winslow
so the recommendation of this sat out in
the report is as follows recommendation
little one
that the progress made in the
preparation of the local development
plan review be noted
and to the council that the regulation
18 issues and options document for
public consultation in accordance with
the regulations and the malden district
statement of community involvement 2021
appendix one be approved do i have a
second to please cancel this way thank
you
members questions
uh councillor chana
thank you chairman i don't know which
way you want to do this um but just in
light of what mr winslow said regarding
obviously the main embodiment of the
report he did refer to the consultation
obviously this is going to counsel for
council to agree and then we'll go out
to consultation now i am aware that that
is likely then to take in the christmas
and new year period possibly
and that's an area of concern to me
chairman because i know in the past
people have considered that important
consultations
falling at that time people have got
other issues didn't feel that some way
um it's the council let's put it this
way uh perhaps not engaging in the right
way to ensure everyone's got an
opportunity to consult it has that been
considered at all should the christmas
new year period following this
consultation episode and what mitigation
will we apply to ensure we do give the
residents of this district stakeholders
and others ample opportunity
to be able to
respond should they so wish
mr winslow
thank you chair uh yes this has been um
considered um and um
what tends to happen um as may have
happened before at this council but
certainly happened at other councils
i've worked at is that you have to do
the minimum statutory consultation which
is why it's mentioned as six weeks in
the report but we can add as many weeks
on to the end of that as the committee
or council wishes
so
it really depends on when the
consultation starts and
although we will do as much uh
preparation as we can ahead of
the count head of council and therefore
make an assumption that council may
approve
um we can only go so far because
obviously council's got the ability not
to approve it if it wishes to and send
it back to here to this committee
so i suppose in answer to councillor
chana's question yes we can extend it
beyond the six weeks and um it's best
practice to do so for precisely the
reason she refers to
so if we count christmas as a
non-working week
and take that into account in terms of
that six week span yeah
i've got various points on the issues
and options areas you know thought i
don't know if you want me to
go through them here now there are a
number or wait till it gets to council
or whatever or i know it's a
consultation document so i could write
in
however there are some concerns that i
do have regarding i i consider possible
emissions
within the document
uh
and is this is this changes you want to
be made to the report counselor channel
well if i give an indication check okay
that'll be okay and then you know i'm
happy um yeah see you soon give us an
example yeah i'll give you a couple of
examples and if it's easier to submit
them
before it goes to council or something i
don't know if it's a possibility um so
page 81 4.5 we have we have appendix one
accessibility and it goes on about rail
and i'm going the pricy now obviously it
goes on about rail inside the district
then states bus and taxi services where
the only other transport options
available to other areas i think
relating to north that's not strictly
true because north of the district does
actually it's not rail um inside the
district but clearly the north of the
district does have
opportunities for rail it's not just
bass and taxi because we have whittam
and hatfield federal stations so i felt
that actually needed some qualification
chairman because i don't believe that's
a wholly accurate statement and then if
i give another um example um 9.12 on
page 94 of appendix one this is what i'm
referring to
it says
it may look um to allocate additional
sites in the towns or villages in the
east of the district well to my
knowledge we've only got one town in the
use of the district and i think that's
burnamon crouch and or along the rail
line that terminates at southminster and
so it's all again about development in
the east chairman so i just make that
point in the issue plural of towns when
i think the east only has one
and then i do feel in
page 97 appendix 1 9.20 there's no
mention of stations again railway
stations or connections with strategic
route the a12 which has been mentioned
earlier on in an introduction to the
report so there's various other ones but
that's the indication chairman where i
am concerned and then i am i'm going to
say this could go against actually the
trust that i see on a council of voice
does but there's something which says
and it does actually tie in with some of
that strategy of affordable housing
we've just agreed on rspd
9.21 on appendix 1 says
most affordable housing would be
provided in all thorn north fanbridge
and southminster
i think that gives an indication it
sounds as though there'd be a great
influx and i declare an interest i live
in northorne
away from the railway station other
things but what i would say is and i
represent parishes in the east of the
area obviously
that gives to me an impression we're
sort of saying that everyone's going to
want to have
large
whatever encampments of affordable
housing so does that mean everyone who
wants an affordable house would want to
live in those
three areas should that be the case
that comes transparent to the issues and
options i just think it's so to say it
gives me the feeling that there's going
to be terrific
developments of affordable housing and i
have to say it might go against the
trust i'm part of because we do have
some properties in author already so i
just make a few points jim i've got some
others but i'm happy to talk to you
outside of the meeting if that's
beneficial and before i get before it
goes to council so i think option seven
is is is based on that that is in north
on north america and southwest so it's
just one of the options so that's
probably why it says that on that
particular option
um that isn't necessarily the option
that's going to to move forward it is
just one of the the options and that's
important to remember
a lot of these discussions came up in
terms of our discussion around the
settlement hierarchy
and i know members fed back so i think
one of the things that might be useful
is is for the officers to perhaps
reflect on the settlement boundary again
and and the extra information that we
have
and and make changes and reflect that in
the different options could the officers
do that before it goes to full council
to ensure that the settlement hierarchy
is reflected a bit more in in the
document
mr winslow
sorry yes jeff i mean uh yes we we
certainly can do that i mean we we have
gone through
um
as as you know chair with the working
group we have gone through um the
uh settlement hierarchy and the options
uh on a number of occasions and i i am
aware of the um certainly i'm aware of
the points all the points cancer channel
talks about including the railway lines
outside the districts to the north
um and um
we
can we could certainly do that uh what
would be my concern would be the um
the
strategy resources committee needs to
approve that this today in in order to
uh to recommend it to council as
complete
without further alterations and what i
what i would say in um just as a
uh as a
as possible solution is that this is a
consultation document and all
counsellors in the council are not
precluded from responding to the
consultation
themselves
so if we go back to
chairman just when i go back then so
it's just on my point about the first
one i guess in particular where it says
about the railway line
um being obviously the
railway branch line and then saying
other areas it's then it does clearly
state then states bus and taxi services
with the only other transport option
really for north and that i don't feel
is totally factual chairman i think
i'm trying to point it out yeah and we
did talk about railway stations and
nowhere and strategic links to the a12
and it's not not necessarily
encapsulated in the document now i did
state at that time i think we're all we
sit in working groups but equally when
we see a report come forward we have
different thoughts we hear things i am
aware there is interest in this document
in fact i will say i've had a very very
good response i would say
and not only me it went to all members
from a member of the public already and
my advice has been i afford it to
officers that to wait till it goes out
to consultation and make sure those
those points they're putting forward
because they are good points i'm not
saying whether the right or wrong points
but um to then have the opportunity for
formal consideration through that
process so there is going to be interest
and i know the officers have indicated
that they are happy to go out and to
parishes i believe i'm correct on that
aren't i mr wimslow i think virtual and
i certainly should be asking telling my
parishes there is that option available
mr winslow
um but just in terms of the point about
clarifying about railway lines in the
north i wonder whether through your
chair the committee would allow that or
allow the final wording of that to be
agreed post meeting and delegated to
officers perhaps in consultation with
you or
i'm i say i'm i'm quite happy for that
to happen so as part of the
the go to council but
members and
and then there is a revision of it
before it gets to full council as long
as other members are happy for me to to
do that and take that that role
i'm going to go to
say
council durham i'm going to go to canada
yeah just a very very quick point um
just going on to the the um
the sixth bullet point on on 4.1 which
addresses the
housing needs and the numbers and i'm
just wondering um obviously they're
shown on page 91 of the appendix but i'm
just
concerned
that
are we prepared to to
um
in the event that there is a large
increase coming down from government i
think that's a potential we certainly
know
that it's one of the government's
intentions is to build to
build back to prosperity so i think we
could see these uh i mean this was a
major
banana skin at the last ldp
um so are we ready if these numbers that
we get from central government be
increased
and the other banana skin was what
tripped us up last time is the gypsy and
traveller um position and we were
we were only bailed out on that case
when um when the government changed its
definition of
of uh gypsy and traveller
um which
i i think is um
slightly tenuous and maybe subject to
change so i think that's something that
needs to be on our radar if it isn't
already uh i i know from the working
group and the information you know the
call for sites that we had
and the corporate sites that we we
received it it
yeah it outweighs our need in terms of
the potential so i think if the
government does ask us to build more
house or look for more sites those sites
are available because they've come
forward in that in that call for sites
and i think
we've got enough for 20 years or
something if we ever if we if that was
to happen in in some way hopefully it
won't
um so but i think in terms of sites we
do have enough if if there was to be an
increase
am i correct mr winslet
and we certainly have had more land
submitted and we have need for what i
would caveat that with is that all of
those are still subject to appraisal to
determine whether they are all suitable
or sustainable
and the issues and options uh document
consultation itself is likely to
generate the submission of more land as
part of the consultation yeah thank you
mr uh councillor can you see mr boyce
um
the points mrs channel makes are very
interesting and i'm concerned about the
response from mr winslow
that if we don't do it tonight it's it's
not going to be able to get done for
the next council meeting
now that says to me that the next
council meeting on this subject could
last five hours because the purpose of a
committee is to do the work
for the council
and if we can't get it right
before the council meeting
um
then all we're going to have is a long
council meeting
as i said i'm more than happy to from an
office point of view
work to address councillor chana's
concern about the
um
the earlier concern sorry that
councillor boyce
raised just now
to ensure that
that that satisfies the committee
assuming it's delegated to officers in
consultation with you chair okay or
we'll come to that when we get to the
recommendation
uh councillor white
thank you uh mr chairman um the first
thing is is to follow on from what
council channel said that it doesn't
just say um the towns in the east it
also said the larger villages and larger
settlements which i think mostly fall in
the east
and the other thing is i was just
writing down the actual point number i
want to raise on 4.1.3 when you read
that it was about um
supporting um
and allocating land for employment but
at the last um
north west we or one before we had now
an application come forward which
officers had down for approval and
unfortunately did get approved um where
the building land was put forward for
residential
um but the thing is they had only
marketed it for one great big building
um whereas what we need the smaller
buildings like at terms domains they're
always full those little business units
there are always for and i want to
somehow future proof it's that if we do
put land the developers either have to
build a building that can be converted
or they have to do something else not
just say oh sorry it didn't work i mean
it might have been more well i think i
would have gone more into who the
consultation was because i just think
during kobe times it wasn't done
properly and it is a concern there's no
point in allocating land if we're going
to allow it to become housing
is there any way we can put that in i'd
like to like to ask the officers
um yeah i'm just on
4.13 um i mean this is this is part of
this is really part of the discussion
really of the issues facing malden um
i'm facing other locations morden's not
dissimilar uh there
on the point that councillor white
raises about um
you know
developers not marketing the sites for
long enough
and what we have done as the working
group will be aware
is commissioned and employment land and
premises study and one of those
things which we're asking for is advice
on the duration the suitable duration of
marketing so that we can explicitly put
that in the policy which would
strengthen our position in the future
just to come back again and yeah but
it's not just the strength of the
marketing it's who they're marketing to
so it needs to be open marketing and the
other thing i wanted to add is on the
biodiversity and the habitats and nature
conservation and to make sure that when
a site comes forward and it allocates a
particular area
for biodiversity nature that it does
remain that and again doesn't end up
with houses on it you know i think we
just need to really tighten up
on these parts of our uh our ldp because
it's really upsetting when you see this
happening and it is really important
uh mr dodson
thank you chairman um i just wanted to
make an observation on some of the the
comments that have been made and i think
clearly what counselor channel said
earlier around the the railways in the
the
north is something that you know i agree
with mr winslow by delegation with we'd
like to update i think
a lot of the the other points
relate to the comments that will be made
through the consultation
um and it will be an iterative process
in in developing
this and i think some great points being
made
but they are
consultation points rather than points
regarding the report thank you
and and i agree mr doesn't that yeah
this is to put forward our options so
that we can then develop what our ldp is
this isn't creating the ldp it's saying
these are the things that we could do in
our ldp and then from that we can
hopefully produce the best ldp
that's that's possible um and that's the
whole point of going through this
process
um yeah we need to ensure that the
document is right when it goes out to
consultation but the whole point of this
is that we when that comes back we can
then make the changes necessary and to
cancel the swain next
thank you so much a couple of points um
firstly on
option for
the reference to pepper potting i know
that the county council's commented that
they um
would well would not
countenance it um so i wonder whether we
ought to reword that option for
um to along the lines of uh widely
distributed rather than pep plotting
and referring to most settlements rather
than all settlements
um but to which would cover it um and
avoid this uh
contentious term of pepper potting um
my view on this mr winslow
um but we've got to remember really that
the consultation is we're trying to
reach out to the public in a
as the lion's share of the audience
really um on um on what the ldp could do
um and the very and the issues that it's
facing pepper potting um although that
sounds very um a very informal way of
describing um how to distribute growth
um it's it is it is used in the planning
system um particularly when trying to uh
to talk in layman's terms as planners
often get told to do more of in future
in respect of the points with the county
council yes they've indicated to us that
they wouldn't support that going forward
well they'll make that point in the
consultation and give hopefully the
council
more detailed reasons why they wouldn't
so that you then as the committee when
the comments come back can determine
whether or not um
you you should agree with the county
council or not and continue with it so
my advice would be to leave it as it is
um and uh and and wait for the
consultation comments to come in
okay and
understood my other second point i think
if i heard councillor durham
um right um is that um we should be
prepared to query the total number of
housing
that um may be sort of handed down to us
um
i did
query basically the numbers for the
current ldp at the later the last
inspection which was before i was a
councillor
um and uh as on the argument that it was
totally out of proportion to what um
warranted in the district and i think we
should be um
prepared to question the numbers that um
are spewed out by the
office for national statistics
i i'm sure we we will do that as much as
we can
councillor lagan
thank you chair um
it's interesting that mr winslow that
you
we have to take this forward and get
this done quite quickly as an options
document it just intrigues me ahead of
the timeliness considering the
importance of it and i get the
consultation requirements
as a consultation document the contents
in it is a good document
i'm very very pleased with the document
there's a consultation document read by
the public it can lead and influence
people's decision to make comments in a
certain way
so i think what council channel said is
absolutely spot on because there is
there's some detail here that really
needs to be fleshed out
on lots of different aspects and i've
got a couple jumped out to me in 9.7 it
just talks about options for growth
within the ldp and i'm not going to
spend a lot of time on it but just to
try and reiterate my point it talks
about small and medium building
companies have found it difficult to
build in more condition because the lack
of smaller located sites and windfall
opportunities could be having an effect
on job availability growth uh skills in
the sector it could be slowing down the
opportunity to bring forward housing
more quickly i want more details on what
they actually are
if i was making a determination on that
to support or not to support to comment
on that i'd rather have a little bit
more devil in the detail
and something that does concern me if
this goes out in its format he's on
section 16 on page 103 16.4 it talks
about bradwell
and the bradwell b potential site
because it's designed we know it's a
national policy it's not for us to
determine but it says in in this text
the policy position that the council
supports it if it can be demonstrated
the nuclear sector development
associated major infrastructure will
make a meaningful contribution to a low
carbon economy and bring potentially so
significant economic benefits to the
area well i i hark back to one of the
reasons why we started an ldp review was
a debate in the chamber that this
council this reiteration the council may
not support new nuclear bradwell b
so i'm a little bit concerned that
that's actually in there
and i i don't feel comfortable but it's
by saying
you know it's at a level much higher
than what we can influence
and the significant destruction of that
area and the 15 year old build and the
proven
carbon destruction that it would bring i
don't think that rings true
it's more of a political statement that
the government bring in that we seem to
have to adhere to so i can't sit there
and say 16.4 is something i i'm pleased
about
but but again that's not in the final
ldp
it's again it's it's open to
consultation so at the uh in terms of
the final we might not put yeah that in
there that and that's the crucial thing
yeah
yeah i'll get that chair and i
understand i understand the concept of
that yeah but it also leads people to
make the decisions and i think i think i
rarely i do agree with council channel i
think we should there's more detail that
needs to be done and there needs to be
more more care because i i'm worried
about that statement specifically
because it's massive and i read earlier
on that we need to look at housing
potential if the bill goes ahead fine
with that that's logical and that should
be put in the ldp
but but not that statement that's
council again uh cancer channel you've
been waiting patiently no chairman
that's fine thank you i mean regarding
the railway stations there's another
area but i'll talk to you outside the
committee about that what i would say
and i appreciate what mr winslow said
and i appreciate what council of voices
said but let's bear in mind a working
group does not make decisions it does
the work has the discussion and it goes
forward to a parent committee now
tonight
mr winslow no disrespect to mr winslow
saying like we've got to get this and go
to council there's only 10 councils or
whatever here that's only a third of the
membership it is a very important
document so when it does go to council
if it does take a bit of time for
members to air their concerns or come up
with comments the council is the place
for it to be heard and then it might be
agreed to change things or not i don't
know but i think we shouldn't
underestimate um allowance for the
council when it does go to council have
the opportunity to discuss we might
think we've got it right as the
committee and the working group but
actually there's two thirds of the
council who may actually have things
that we haven't considered or thought at
because we might be too close to it
sometimes so um i just think if there's
debate at council and it's so be it and
it's you know i i don't i would not
expect a document like this just to be
nodded through at council if i'm always
bearing in mind the history of the
previous ldp and how long debates and
that and that talk and that's not being
critical at all it's just that i think
it may be debated by those councillors
that haven't had involvement so far or
bring up issues and they can be
explained whether they're valuable at
that time or a matter for the results of
the consultation when that's um you know
um finished and then comes back for
further consideration by
so so could we
have a recommendation that this goes
back to the working group and then from
the working group it goes straight to
full council is that possible
no okay it was just a thought
uh councillor white that's right i'm
sorry to come back again but thank you
for indulging me um the first thing i
want to come back with um with the
discussion with the original ldp all
members were involved it wasn't just a
committee or anything else we were all
involved and on 19.4 it talks about the
um public transport infrastructure which
is county councils i think main reason
they don't like the potting is they
don't get the money
um but when we had the first workshops
back for the current ldp
um we drew we're all sitting groups at
the minerva center and we all in groups
worked out we had offices with us where
we would prefer the development to be
and when we put in the south linebrook
way we actually said providing there was
a relief go road going around by berry
farm and coming out in um
on the o414 and that we'd make it
pedestrian where the current road is and
that was all well and good but when it
came down to being developed oh sorry
that's not financially viable so i do
think that we need to be really careful
about what we're actually putting in
because it was everything's done with
the best intentions but they don't
always work out and that was
a really disappointing one that we
allowed the housing there and they
didn't get any infrastructure
no benefits for the residents at all
particularly coming from the this the
south and the east um you know who have
to use that road they're now still going
through pearly okay can't answer durham
yeah thank you i'm don't wonder along
with this any longer but um item 15
which is tackling the climate change i'm
just wondering
whether some of these questions are
actually in conflict with national
policy of achieving net zero
um and whether that we need to be
perhaps a bit more aligned um
with the essex county uh objectives and
indeed central government to achieving
net zero
and i don't know if members
were aware that um
because the wind stopped blowing last
last week
they actually had to fire up a
coal-fired power station because the uh
otherwise the country would have run out
of electricity so we are going to have
to find some way and that is going to be
decommissioned so if that happened next
year
i'm afraid the lights would have gone
out so but i think it's
and i'm a little bit concerned that the
tackling climate change which is
probably one of the biggest issues we've
got he's actually a very small part of
this but
i'm sure it will develop
mr winslow any final comments
just through your chat just start on
in terms of the climate change questions
i mean the que the questions that are in
are in there um and we have had
conversations about the uh essex climate
commission obviously there's work going
on inside the council at the moment on
the climate action strategy as well
um the questions really are trying
although national policy may well change
in respects of all of this and we are we
are sort of planning in uh where the
goal posts may move um and i i know that
some of the member feedback that has
happened to officers so far is can we
try and do more than what national
policy is pushing for and can we be a an
exemplar authority in respect of that so
um but the questions are there um to
enable that sort of feedback to to come
back to to clarify if necessary
cancer sign with it was a quick point
it refers to what council
mentioned under 16.4
the wording there if it can be
demonstrated that
would make a meaningful contribution to
a low carbon it's not it rather looks as
though we're in a position to determine
whether it does demonstrate it or not
okay
um
so if we go back to the
recommendation
uh which is
that um
it was the council
so based on further feedback from
members
and that goes to
uh
mr winslow and miss
altoff
uh
shortland
in terms of that feedback and then
making necessary amendments to that
document for the approval of the
chairman before it goes to full council
can we amend that as the recommendation
to
yeah
okay
so recommendation one is is
to be noted that the progress made the
preparation local development plan and
then
recommendation two that the regulation
18 issues an options document will be
given further revision with input from
members
and to go to offices and for the
chairman of snr to approve those
amendments before it is presented to
full council
okay agreed
thank you very much oh
sorry german you're going to need a
deadline for those comments aren't you i
i am
because we don't really want a week
before
full council
so could we say
by
the first week in october
is that acceptable
councils when
5th of november bonfire night
does that then give you a month
you chairman that's probably quite quite
tight in terms of the the committee
deadlines could you um confirm that do
you have those
so by the first of october
why they by
where are we now we're on there
yeah so by the end of next week
so any amendments so and could we send
out an email to members asking for those
yeah to all members
um so that everybody is being advised of
that
sorry chairman just just to confirm
that's all members of this committee
yes
and hopefully other people have read it
as well but
okay
yes okay all right
thank you very much
is that a good virus
okay thank you very much members
so we move on to agenda item nine
approval to consult on the woodfield
cottages conservation heir proposal
and giraffe would feel gorgeous as local
listed building consent order on pages
119 to 232
mr halsen conservation and heritage
specialist
thank you chair and hi everyone
so
this is this item seeking approval to
publicly consult on
two initiatives aimed at improving the
condition and appearance of woodfield
cottages in haybridge
hopefully you've all had a chance to
look through the report and appendices
but just to provide a bit of background
and a brief overview
the cottages are grade two listed for
their architectural and historic
interest
they have historic interest as a special
example of victorian planned industrial
housing community
they were built
in 1873 as um
houses for the employees of benthal's
agricultural works um which you all all
know
uh
dominated and transformed the parish of
haybridge in the 19th century
and they also have architectural
interest
as a pioneering
example of
mass concrete construction although
that's not obvious from the outside
also
they were first built with flat roofs so
very early example of flat roofed
cottages
the current pitched roofs were added in
1918 because the flat roofs leaked
but you can see that evidence for the
flat roofs and the attics
still
um
and in the appendices uh to the report
there are various reconstruction
drawings that show what the cottages
would have looked like before they had
the pitch throughs added
the cottages were listed in 1971
but
by that date they had already undergone
a degree of alteration
typically replacement windows and
porches um
and the cottages have continued to be
modernized um uh to the present day
in many instances with list of building
consent but there have been several
cases without listed building consent
and
and and some less than sympathetically
some of the cottagers unfortunately one
in particular has fallen into a very
poor condition
there are several outstanding
enforcement cases and i would say the
cottages are among the most challenging
list of buildings in the district um
historic england considered the cottages
for de-listing in 2019 due to the extent
of alteration but
concluded emphatically that they do
still merit their listed status they are
unusual and important buildings despite
their
alteration and indeed many of the
residents said that they
didn't want they wanted their houses to
remain uh listed
um
but historically recognized that the
challenges
that the cottagers present
and they have offered to work with
molden district council to improve the
fate of these buildings so two positive
and proactive measures are now being
proposed
first is to designate a conservation
area
and appendix one to the report is a
document called the woodfield cottages
conservation area proposal and character
statement
and that
articulates the justification for the
conservation area um
on the grounds that
the settlement represents
to use the terminology of legislation
it's an area of special architectural
and historic interest the character and
appearance of which it is desirable to
preserve and enhance
because it's not just the buildings
which are important the spaces around
the buildings and the access lanes and
gardens all have value
the document provides detailed
information on the history of
the building's guidance on sympathetic
alterations and it identifies
opportunities for enhancement so all the
enhancement opportunities are listed on
uh pages 25 and 26
of the conservation area proposal
um
one of the main advantages to
designating a conservation area is that
it would create the possibility of
entering into a conservation area
partnership scheme with historic england
through which grant funding would be
offered for enhancement work and that's
actually something historic england
actively invited us
to do
that but the conservation area needs to
be designated before we can tap into
that funding
and then the second initiative is to
establish uh what's called a local
listed building consent order the draft
of which is
reproduced as appendix 2.
so at present because they're listed
buildings
list of building consent is required for
any alteration which affects their
special character
so
applications are free but
there's a degree of
paperwork involved
you normally have to prepare
architectural drawings and it takes
eight weeks to determine
what a local listed building consent
order does is grant automatic consent
for selected types of alteration as long
as they're undertaken in accordance with
an approved specification and
woodfield cottages are ideal for this
type of order because
all the cottages were built to the same
design so
what is sympathetic for one of them is
sympathetic for all of them really
um
and by cutting out the bureaucracy or
blister building consent this order
would make it easier for owners to
undertake
sympathetic and restorative work
and so the authorized works
include the replacement of non-original
windows doors porches
re-rendering painting
the replacement of rainwater goods
and among the authorized works is the
installation of
painted timber sliding sash windows
which would
replicate the original design
but would incorporate very discreet slim
profile double glazed units and
we've worked on the design of those with
um local joiners
and it'd be very hard to tell that they
are double glazed looking at them but
hopefully they will appeal to the owners
of many of these cottagers which have uh
single glazed windows dating from
the 60s
so as well as improving the couch the
buildings they will make them more
thermally efficient
i will just finally say that very few
local listability content orders have
been established nationally
this would be the first example in east
anglia so
as with the stone mary's
aerodrome heritage partnership agreement
uh set up a few years ago which works
extremely well to be another instance of
molden you know doing something quite
innovative in terms of heritage
management
so
the items seeking approval to publicly
consult on these proposals um
consultation on a local listed building
consent order is a statutory requirement
um and there's a process to follow for
that but interestingly consultation on
the designation of a conservation area
is not a requirement but
clearly it's good practice to do so and
i think the success of a project like
this will depend on the degree of
enthusiasm and cooperation of residents
um and we'll have to sort of take the
feedback into account very carefully
and then just finally
2023
will be the 150th anniversary since the
cottages were built
so
with the proposed measures in place it's
hoped that that anniversary could be
celebrated with the consciousness facing
brighter prospects
okay
thank you mr houston uh one thing i
would like to say
you're talking about the enthusiasm of
the residents well yeah one of the
things that in terms of your report and
it's very decent and very good report it
shows your your enthusiasm for
conservation and it shows you know how
keen you are to do these things and it
is
a fantastic report
so the recommendations are sat out in
the report as follows that little one
that the woodfield cottages conservation
area proposal and character appraisal is
approved for public consultation and
little two that the draft woodfield
cottage's local listed building consent
or order is approved for public
consultation to have a secondary
councillor white thank you very much
uh any comments members councillor white
thank you instrument i just i'd say i
agree that this is a really really good
piece of work it's really interesting
reading about the previous
residents
and one of my queries was going to be on
the funding for particular number 127
that's quite um
in a bit of a poor condition and i think
that if we can get the funding to help
these residents upgrade
the houses so they all look um similar i
think would be absolutely fantastic and
i'm really looking forward to seeing it
done and well done for starting this
work i'm really excited about it
council thompson
thank you very similar comments from me
um
thank you very much to mr house and it's
a brilliant report they always are
a lot of work's gone into this a lot of
thought um i can't think of a single
thing against it unless another member
comes up with something but i'd like to
thank him and commend it thank you okay
can you plea say it's very good that mr
houston is appreciated by us all uh
it's it's the mr house and appreciation
society so
if you could now keep comments to the
report rather than mr house and
appreciation society that i'm going to
move to to councillor durham
yeah thank you um
i i totally echo previous comments
that's as far as i'll go um mr houston
knows
what i think of his work and it's
exemplary i i think this is a it's a
fantastic piece of work and i think this
this is not
just in relation to
uh single buildings or group of
buildings it's actually the whole
development is actually really
significant in its own right
yes of course some have been changed and
had weird and wonderful porches and and
additions
but actually the social history that
this whole development represents i
think is essential
to to maintain
and uh you know i commend it and looking
looking through you know seeing a lot of
these residencies were lived in by
families of up to nine people
it's
you know i i think it as i said in terms
of social history of malden and
haybridge and and indeed it's it's um
industrial history with with bental's is
absolutely vital and i totally support
um that the um
that this should be preserved okay
very well said uh cancer voice
uh thank you chairman can i ask uh mr
house and if um these
houses before they had the roof
added
were similar to the i think they were
called holds ones at silver end
was thousand
yeah
those well the ones at silver end are uh
younger they're sort of 1920s aren't
they so yeah yeah
yes they're having flat flat roofs was
really unusual in the
yeah it 1870s a more uh
um 1930s thing silver and doesn't it
yeah yeah i'm sorry i just i just
mentioned it um because of the flat roof
issue yeah
and um
an industrial um house yeah thank you
council voice
okay
uh council channel
thank you did you keep it to well yeah
well i would echo around the comments i
was going to say the fan club of mr
houston but i mean i think we will look
forward to his reports when we see them
on the agenda can i just start sparing
your mind um you know the detail of this
just to be clear of clarification really
um where does this thing go i mean
obviously you know about him we'll know
about it as a council
uh do you then write to the
people of woodfield cottages or where is
that then recorded bearing in mind the
changes that might occur as a result of
this there must be a process i would
imagine there it has to be uh detailed
somewhere um searches and
searches are covered etcetera um on
exchange regarding um
ownership
so this is in terms of the consultation
well we'll be writing to all the all the
owners as part of the consultation it's
a public consultation so if you're going
on our website and um they're all
publicly available so
then when it becomes apparent if you'd
like as a result of that where does then
all this get recorded
because things then must through the you
know time goes on and a change of hands
occur so it's all we know about it you'd
know about it where is it recorded so
that this is a matter of record
conservation area will be a local land
charge so whenever they purchase the
house they'll
and all these documents will be on on
the on the website so um they'll be
brought to any any new purchases of
attention so i mentioned searches that
will be there
thank you very much
uh so can we agree this viral sentiment
thank you very much
so we now move on to agenda item 10
response to rochford district council
development capacity letter august 2020
found on pages 233-244
it's back to mr winslow again
thank you chair
on the 9th august 2021
morton district council received a
letter from rocha district council
entitled capability for accommodating
development needs the rochford new local
plan this is found in appendix 2d a
report and explains that like malden
district council rocha district council
has commenced a review of its local plan
and it's also currently exploring how it
could accommodate its growth needs over
20 years
sorry my laptop moved
rocha district council has reviewed its
land supply and at this early stage it
is concerned that it will not be able to
accommodate all of its development needs
without reviewing its boundaries of the
london metropolitan greenbelt which
cover much of the district's rural area
this shortfall could amount to between
1700 and
3200 homes
we have been informed
the committee must note that green belts
are subject to very strict controls for
reviewing boundaries established by the
national planning policy framework and
case law which includes a need to
demonstrate exceptional circumstances
in accordance with the mppf and the due
to cooperate rocha district council of
their forewritten to their neighbouring
authorities to understand whether any of
their neighbours can help meet this need
before they consider whether they need
to use the exceptional circumstances
tests to review their green belt
boundaries i set out in the committee
report in order to inform rochford's
assessment of whether those
circumstances exist
and to comply with the requirements of
the national planning policy framework
malden district council is being asked
whether it could
advise whether any of rochford's
identified development needs could be
accommodated in the modern district
either now or in the future
section four of this report sets out
several matters which the district
council needs to modern district council
sorry needs to consider when compiling
its response to the request from
rochford
and to summarize those are the duty to
cooperate which we were talking about
earlier this evening the stage of plan
making uh that rochford and maldon are
both at
national greenbelt policy
what are called the housing market area
geographies which is how the housing
markets work
and the point to note here is that
malden and rochford are in different
housing market areas
and existing arrangements and protocols
section 5 of the report concludes that
taking the above matters into account
morton district council cannot
categorically confirm at the moment due
to the very early stage of its own local
development plan review whether it is
able or not to assist rochford with
accommodating housing needs
therefore given the boundary between the
two districts is a body of water the
river crouched with no shared crossing
points between the two
and has the housing market relationship
is not very strong
uh it's recommended that for oshawa
district council are asked to exhaust an
evidence to malden district council
that uh the essex planning officers
association's unmet housing needs
protocol which we are both signed up to
has been fully complied with prior to
morden being able to make any further
comment or agreement with ruptured
regarding this matter i'm happy to take
questions thank you mr smith and i one
thing that
i would like to comment on uh before we
go to recommendation is uh your the
letter that has been produced puts those
days across in a very very professional
and uh competent way so there's a very
very good letter so the recommendation
is
that the response to rochefort district
council letter be approved as set out in
appendix one do i have a second of
councillor white thank you
uh questions councillor white
mr chairman um yeah just so yeah i
really like the response it's the
comment about the water which is all
true and they're all valid points um and
and just say it's not really a question
that um i remember at a particularly
hostile meeting in northumbridge i don't
know how many years ago
um the residents were going absolutely
potty and um because of the proposed i
know 600 houses or whatever it was but
what was really funny was wooden
pharah's there and stood up and said oh
we support it as long as you'll take 150
of our
affordable housing requirements which
didn't go down very well and this is a
similar sort of thing okay amazing
counselor
yeah thank you thank you very much much
it's it's a very good letter and it's a
very um professional and
polite way of saying no but
but you know actually the the water
boundary is not as relevant as you might
think because this is only
what they're asking is to offset some of
their numbers against ours so it could
be anywhere in the district it could be
north of the district so so i think
actually this this you know it doesn't
have to
be contagious with their land back well
there isn't a land boundary but
um i i think that our strongest point is
on the the fact of our early stage of
the
review of the ldp yeah um but as i said
you know the the water although it's a
it's a nice one he's actually not
relevant okay let's cancel cancer
channel
thank you chairman
just my being my usual pedantic self and
housekeeping i notice we talk about the
council's view and then the committee i
take it is in order for this response to
be from the committee uh that's not
really my question and who will be
signing off the letter just so joel's
faithfully so i wasn't quite clear who
would be signing off the letter chairman
i'm not sure he'll be signing it off mr
winslet um so
uh yeah
we hadn't i think agreed that internally
within offices um at the moment but i
think it would probably come from paul
okay
thank you
uh so
can we agree this for our ascent members
okay thank you very much
so we move now to agenda item 11 which
is supplementary estimates environments
and the use of reserves
uh pages 243-2
mr leslie director of resources thank
you chair
this is a regular uh report that
provides details there any supplementary
estimate survivements that are required
to be reported to the committee in
accordance with the financial
regulations at this time there are two
violence contained in the report at
paragraph 3.2.1
the first one is for approval
where the approved ldp budget is now
being allocated to more detailed codes
falling more refined expenditure plans
so that will help with monitoring the
second one is two note relating to a
correction of a cost center code thank
you thank you mr leslie
so the recommendations are set out in
the report are as follows uh
recommendation that wonder the
environment one as detailed in paragraph
3.2.1
of this report to be approved and little
two that environment 2 as detailed in
paragraph 3.2.1 of this report be noted
can i have a second of police councillor
thompson
are there any questions or comments to
mr leslie
nope okay can we agree that virus sent
members
thank you very much
so we now move to item number 12.
any other items of business at the
chairman of the committee decides are
urgent they are arnold
so we now move on to item 13 the
exclusion of the press and public and
that is to resolve that under section
108 brackets 4 of the local government
act 1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting for the following items of
business on the grounds that they
involved the likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in paragraph
three of part one of shield schedule 12a
to the act and that this satisfies the
public interest test
can i have a second to please councillor
swain thank you
is it can we agree that via ascent
okay thank you very much
so we now need to wait until the
meetings uh
off the street
gentlemen um i've
not been able to get this report um okay
as uh miss bird knows that often um
my ipad throws
out the ability for me to see pmc
stuff and
i have to keep getting on to her to ask
how to
get it back again i don't know why the
system